what's going on a reject nation it's
Greg outta here and it's John here so we
just came back from watching slash the
musical yes Clark wolf produced and it
was one of the stars of this musical and
it's like a horror themed comedy a
slasher a spoof of some sort yeah it was
hilarious awesome [ __ ] sings and
acts on this and she's fantastic and it
produces yes she's amazing in this and
if you guys are out in LA I think they
have one more show or two more shows
they have a couple they might be pretty
sold it yeah
you guys if you have the chance to get a
ticket here if you live in the LA area
do yourself a favor and go watch but
while we were there online and search
slash the musical because you can leave
here and download the track while we
were out there we got notifications and
a bail creation trailer number two now I
know we're behind on some movie trailers
John and I had taken the weekend to
ourselves for some thing so we're a
little bit behind but we figured all
right let's start catching out with a
little water boys trailers cut through
it is halo this just drops now just a
new
we created to be a girl again she wanted
permission to mine the doll
we still realized it wasn't locked it
away we're not helping the girls
experiment this very orphanage you know
Carl from us again you would eat it
keep it with you speak on Christmas
shoot retreat
[Music]
delicious you help me doll in the
waitress you mustn't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
horror violence and terror the first one
rated all so scary that it's read what
that's good after that rating says okay
yeah I was imagine no no I mean I
wait there's a last one maybe they're
finding their footing with this
conjuring universe because I got a more
conjuring vibe from this trailer not
getting a never standards have
especially the first half of the trailer
I was thinking like oh this feels more
like the conjuring yeah a conjuring
needs Ouija - yeah you know so we're
going back to the Dust Bowl and III like
kind of everything I see here I like the
sort of girl home orphan interesting and
I think Miranda Otto and whatever that
guy's name is antelope hoglet I yeah
yeah guys and everything and I think
they're both terrific actor I like that
they're gonna kind of leave this you
know one thing I like from the trailer
is the characters don't seem like
they're stupid people yeah you know and
that's something that Han that sounds
like a dumb statement but burro or movie
has a lot of credit for a situation like
this London it's in a different time in
place where yeah even more so it isn't
it doesn't feel like why don't you just
do this or why don't you just do that
better kind of out in the middle of
nowhere
yeah I like the setup of they're trying
to save their daughter they think it's
their daughter communicating it's not
their daughter and now they have this
demon amongst them and they're kind of
find redemption it seems like they're
really playing with the religious factor
a lot that's one thing I think this
movie is doing a little more job or
student why it feels a little more like
a conjuring because the
turning has its religious horror
elements very much present in them and
that seems to really be honing in on the
religious horror aspect yeah you know
it's like we don't know for sure if it's
like a specific type of religion that
that are going after it's like yes or
focusing on the calf like perspective of
this yeah we're using the religious
genre of horror at a very specific time
period as well which the religious genre
even more effective I feel yeah so and
it's all unfolding you know I'm
wondering that's going to do some
elements you know how much he like
starts to walk again
the character is paraplegic and then
she's starting to walk so I'm wondering
if it might do because one thing I like
in certain foreign movies I think of
like poultry guides for example when
they add in like fantasy element to it
yeah maybe it's a good thing what's
happening right yeah yeah the trailer is
going straight for four but I'm
wondering if in the actual film itself
they might hone in on an element of this
is an angelic being or sorcery some on
the tearing or yeah I'd like it in a way
that seems innocuous or seems almost
warm but of course not even remain that
way what I love about the conjuring
movies is there there's a life to them
and that comes out personality of the
characters you know I get the conjuring
here's a whole life scene where ed
Warren's playing the guitar and Elvis
song or something yeah yeah family and
the family is bonding over that moment
yeah yeah it's just a moment for the
character and this trailer is giving us
a lot of brimmed our seriousness
throughout but where you get a you get
this a whole wide cast of character you
got none of their I mean yeah you got
happy little Toggl II I think it's like
I say his name who's you know this seems
like really somber but then you got all
the kids in here so I'm imagining it
there'd be a lot of life in the personal
life of the characters and from the
director of lights-out that's something
he did with his characters in that movie
which made the movie much more
entertaining was the personality of the
human beings in the story and I'm hoping
that's really present here otherwise we
can get kind of just a slow down film
and when I think if he infuses that
level of fun from characters that could
really uplift this
yeah well and I like that this is you
know if he's doing kind of the studio
horror track I like where this is going
from lights out because light does burn
modern movie
you know a lot of modern elements in
this you know going back to period and
even filling into the holes if we're
tying this all into the conjuring one of
the things the conjuring has is the end
Loraine you know relationship and I feel
like taking this into a place where you
have at least a patriarch and a
matriarch of this household could kind
of do that they're they're the religious
ones or at least you know they're where
the religion kind of stems from in this
home there are lots of details and
elements and things that make me pretty
interested in this you know as compared
to the first one that didn't and that
director David Sandberg can do that like
I know any member Andy Samberg is a good
horror director don't know why I was
very surprised doesn't happen for for
and also I you know they're putting I
don't remember how big James Wong his
name was the first time we did this but
they're certainly putting it on there
now and I was feel like you know he's
got to at least be shepherding these and
that then gives me some some form of
confidence you know if I am annoyed by
universe stuff these days i am i think
the conjuring a universe was better
before they made it crystal clear that
they're calling in to you for yeah I
don't like the phrases on a converse
because part of the thing is these
stories aren't universal like they're
not huge yeah these horror thrives of an
intimate environment and they're coming
out with a nun they're coming out with a
crooked man as well we all refer to it
as the conjuring universe but the fact
of they're saying for some reason is
kind of bothers me laundry then maybe I
shouldn't be annoyed about it but I am
because the conjuring universe sounds
like a joke yeah like it sounds like it
shouldn't be or or use it like it's just
a nitpick it's just a semantic error but
to me yeah I would have preferred they
came up with their own way of saying
that instead of saying the conjuring is
because ah it just feels like they're
trying to make something big out of
something that's not as big as that is
and yeah I'm yes it just seems weird to
me but whatever
yeah cuz good it's like because I'm
wondering like should I be annoyed
because we've all been callin it a
conjuring universe with I don't do I
learn hasn't been an official like
statement about we're building a
universe you know yeah I mean like this
I do think what they're trying to do
with this set of tails is on paper
charming I guess because now that we
have the nun and now that we have the
crooked man they're all different
aesthetically and alike we know creepy
doll but you know creepy nun conjures up
a different kind of religious horror to
me anyway and then so does the crooked
man and what I think though is this is
evolved into a more natural universe
than a lot of these other universes I
don't feel like we men did the conjuring
they were like we're gonna give you be
universally you know yeah when they spun
off Annabella boy sure I can spell it's
a real but i way anyway on the contrary
universe is coming yeah that's a real
thing you know they're in their museum
every yeah it sounds like i I preferred
it when it felt natural before they
kicked in the door were like we're at
university yeah
check it out guys the CCU is coming but
aside from that a little enjoys for the
[ __ ] trailer putting those words over
there the trailer for the movie itself
looks like a pretty good horror film and
I'm more than willing to check it out
made me want to see this yeah alright
what do you guys think of the conjuring
trailer Annabelle conjuring and all
those creators Trey Lyra Connery Hannah
Annabelle first again yeah Annabelle
would have the nun show of it should be
a post-credits scene now I wondered you
saw post credit on your [ __ ] and that's
the thing I guess is like that's what I
don't want is like a but like an
Annabelle is spun off I don't want them
to start doing like boom crossover all
this character here's the nut hallway
there's the crooked man oh wow they're
all the same place ago this just makes a
bunch of go stories with a similar
Tambor this trailer has made it official
we have five cinematic
universes now and there are only more to
come morning I can't wait
rude subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell dat John Humphrey
on Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum House who also does many
a good for and you can go check our
exclusive perks and rewards over at
patreon.com slash the real rejects
laughter they own